[Music]
foreign
friends we are coming up on the end of
March and that means it is time once
again for me to share my playlist with
you and for you to request a song for me
to flow up to Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
show you a few songs that I've really
been enjoying for you to select one for
me to perform to you at the end of the
month but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca becklinen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
cool so this is now the third month that
I've been doing this and here's the
drill basically I'm going to give you
some short Snippets of flow uh me
performing to five different songs and I
want you all out there to vote on which
song you'd like to see me do a full flow
session to so how exactly do you go
about selecting the song that I flow out
to I'm so glad you asked all you need to
do is leave a comment with the name of
the song that you most enjoyed watching
me flow out to and the song that gets
the most comments will be the one that I
flow out to next Friday so go ahead and
get that typing finger ready so that you
can tell me what you want to see more of
from me sweet let's get ourselves set up
here all right so our first song here is
going to be if so by Atlas Genius
um I just love how bouncy the hook is in
this makes me feel happy hopefully it
makes you all feel happy too
[Music]
we'll be coming
everybody's faking like they can it
makes it all right
tell me what you want to cause I don't
know
just don't be talking baby
[Music]
all right next up we've got just yet by
for Esme I know absolutely nothing about
this band it just came up in my Apple
music suggested list but um it's got
kind of a mellow almost like sad and emo
vibe to it and I don't know why but it
just kind of spoke to me so see if it
does your YouTube
[Music]
felt the empty space
self-deception
such a dangerous weapon for me
[Music]
your best
all right so let's pick up the mood a
little bit here with sugar and spice by
um I'm not actually sure how to read
this band's name
it looks like it's werewolf but they're
using these instead of the W's so I'm
not sure if it's vervolve or werewolf I
don't know if any of y'all out there
know you can you can leave me a comment
let me know but yeah it's sugar and
spice by werewolf and it's super peppy
it's super fun I dig it
and I'll show you why twice
[Music]
us
all right then next up legendarily I
have a deep and Abiding Love of synth
pop and uh I've put out some stuff from
one of my favorites uh synth pop groups
uh The Naked and Famous on these in past
months and this month I've really been
rocking out to this particular track
from Scottish synth pop group churches
it's called leave a Trace
[Music]
thank you
but I try hard to uncover them
away with everything
anything you ever did was strictly by
Design but you got it wrong
[Music]
and you have
don't need
nothing
all right so for our final entry for the
month we have your heart as a weapon by
pop Etc again I know absolutely nothing
about this band but it's got a real nice
mellow vibe to it that I personally like
a lot
so here it goes
[Music]
a team
it's easy to
do
awesome so those are your five choices
this month what would you like to see me
flow out to next Friday leave me a
comment and let me know did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it and of
course to help my channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible or not
for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people who sit down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
so by heading on over to patreon.com
directs factorpoi and signing up there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out some of my other flow sessions I'll
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching have
yourselves a great weekend and I'll see
you with a new video on Monday
peace